on poursuit donc avec jean françois
ouellet professeur agrégé au département
d'entrepreneuriat et d'innovation hec
montréal bonsoir monsieur ouellette
bonjour alors c'est quoi l'héritage le
jeff bezos c'est ce qu'il est on
commerce de détail ce que steve jobs a
été pour les communications par exemple
que vous êtes détails que nous au détail
en ligne définitivement je pense et
peut-être même plus parce que jusqu'à un
certain point
jeff bezos ce presque inventé le
commerce de détail en ligne comme on le
connaît aujourd'hui alors que steve jobs
ne pas forcément réinventé
l'informatique les l'adapter c'est un
héritage qui est exceptionnel qui va
durer pour plusieurs années la moins que
l'iran de force destructrice de vienne
brouiller les cartes mais j'en vois pas
vraiment que qu'amazon ne serait pas en
mesure de soutenir ou avec laquelle où
les cas elle ne sera pas en mesure de
rivaliser à court et à moyen terme
certainement
et là il quitte son poste de pdg mais on
s'en doute bien
il va conserver une bonne influence sur
l'entreprise amazon n'est ce pas
absolument parce que bon il a bouclé le
siège du président directeur général il
demeure quand même le président du
conseil d'administration et de conseil
dans une situation comme celle ci
l'organe qui est flux largement vois
rien qui donne finalement les ordres
matière de grandes orientations
stratégiques à l'équipe de direction et
moi je verrais très mal son successeur
commencé à s'opposer à lui alors que ce
sera essentiellement quand même son
patron le conseil d'administration il
organes duquel ou auquel plutôt
répondent les pdg de toute organisation
donc son influence votre demeure et très
grand même si du côté opérationnel on
connaît jeff bezos ce qu'on connaît de
lui c'est quelqu'un qui est un
visionnaire d'abord mais c'est aussi un
exécuteur en fait quelqu'un qui met en
exécution finalement sa vision qui la
met en action plutôt de manière
extrêmement précise ce quelqu'un qui en
demande énormément de la part de ses
collaborateurs il a forcé constaté qui
sera plus dans les opérations entre
beaucoup moins comme président du
conseil d'administration mais qu'il donc
en principe la culture pourrait changer
un petit peu au cours des années à venir
cela dit pas un mot il s'est fait
exploser
je pense qu'il sera pas tellement loin
des opérations même quotidienne et je
suis président qui va vous remettre du
mal à se distancer de l'organisation oui
bon son successeur qui s'appelle and dj
5 et qu'est ce qu'on sait de lui
monsieur ouellette bien aussi moins de
choses qu'on essaye de jeff bezos ce
qu'on s'est essentiellement c'est que
c'est celui qui était chargé de mettre
en place et de faire croître la division
des services web en wsk maso web sur six
c'est la division de la zone qui
responsable d'à peu près toutes les
infrastructures en ligne et lorsque vous
êtes un détaillant de la taille de ma
zone mais vous voulez vous assurer que
ce qui était pour le battre il faut pas
structure la plus critique soit soit top
notch comme on dit en latin et force est
de constater que ce pari qui a été
qu'ils étaient réussis et puis amazon
lancé en w est tout simplement parce que
elle était à une certaine époque
insatisfaite des services qui lui
étaient offertes par d'autres tierce
partie a décidé de prendre le taureau
par les cornes pour subvenir à ses
propres besoins ce qui l'a d'ailleurs
déjà menacé le faire dans d'autres
contextes
à commencer par celui de l'acheminement
postales et des services de messagerie
que font les pin ups et autres fedex de
ce monde mais là aujourd'hui monsieur
ouellette vous avez amazon le commerce
en ligne
l'info nuage et qu'il ya des épiceries
elle contenu vidéo amazon ses 1700
milliards de dollars de valeur boursière
ce qu est ce qu amazon est trop gros
aujourd'hui c'est une très bonne
question puis en fait aujourd'hui ce
qu'on sait c'est que la plupart des
organisations créer plus de valeur en
étant ce qu on appelle des petits géants
donc des pme est sensé mais qui sont
très focalisés sur une niche qui
exécutent de manière de manière
impeccable à l'échelle mondiale dans une
maison non simplement que la plupart des
grandes organisations dans ce qu'ils
atteignent une taille plus trop grande
ont tendance à s'encrasser devenu un
moyen innovant moins agile mais le cas
d'amazon c'est le contraire qui se passe
en fait est à ce point tel que je vois
très mal concurrents venir déloger
amazon sur un ou l'autre des des
différentes unités d'affaires qu'elle
exploite que ce soit pour les épiceries
en ligne en fait la simplicité avec
laquelle amazon devrait inventer le
commerçant en ligne
on est en train de l'appliquer
maintenant au commerce de détail
contexte d épicerie au premier chef
c'est quelque chose d'absolument
redoutable je dirais pour la plupart des
organisations qui sont déjà en présence
la même chose pour ce qui est peut-être
moins d'un cas de la télé d'une vidéo
solide absolument surtout en matière de
création de contenu même netflix et
challenge et l'aï mise au défi par
d'autres arrivent à commencer par disney
cela dit pour l'ensemble de l'oeuvre est
amazonie très difficile à déloger parce
qu'ils ont encore une fois entre les
mains ce qui est l'actif le plus
précieux de toute organisation destinée
aux consommateurs ou dont les actifs ont
voué aux dires est directement
consommateurs c'est-à-dire des données
personnelles à votre sujet à mon sujet
au sujet de tout un chacun
quant à nos besoins nos préférences nos
désirs à tel point même qu amazon est en
train de lancer un modèle qui s'appelle
très mauvais français
chip dunlop ce qu'on est tellement
confiant chez amazon qu on vous connaît
bien que on n'attendra pas que vous
commandiez le produit désormais on
s'apprête à vous l'expédier davance est
en train de la chance que ça passe pour
la faire et qu'on voulait expliquer ce
projet connaître monsieur ouellet on va
devoir s'arrêter là toujours merci
beaucoup pour vos explications pour voir
nos émissions en entier rendez vous sur
la chaîne ici et redit